[Aplausos]
gracias muchas gracias a todos y muy
buenos días sí
ubiquémonos en argentina
la zona metropolitana del río de la
plata'
la ciudad en la que la empresa mercedes
benz instaló su fábrica por allá de los
años 50
un buen día ricardo klement el gerente
desapareció
no se supo de su paradero durante algún
tiempo se sospechaba de un secuestro
unos días más tarde todos los periódicos
o los periódicos más importantes del
planeta reportaron que había sido
atrapado
[Música]
y adolf eichmann uno de los criminales
nazis más buscados durante mediados del
siglo pasado llevaba diez años viviendo
en argentina con ese seudónimo richard
klima esta persona había sido el
responsable de la logística en la
fábrica de muerte que fue el holocausto
de holocausto de exterminio del pueblo
judío él literalmente fue el responsable
de la muerte de más de 5 millones de
seres humanos
esta persona fue detenida captada por el
mossad la policía de la inteligencia del
pueblo israelí trasladado a jerusalén
donde fue procesado en un juicio que
llamó la atención mundial en aquella
época
hannah arendt filósofa en función de
periodista cubrió informativamente
hablando del juicio
y al final escribió un libro
espeluznante en más de un sentido pero
muy revelador de muchas cosas y entre
tantas conclusiones ella dijo que si
bien es esa persona ciertamente era
culpable de tantos crímenes también es
cierto que esa persona era víctima de
una enfermedad una enfermedad social una
enfermedad que vivió el pueblo alemán en
aquellos años y esa enfermedad le puso
un nombre le llamó la banalidad del mal
es un proceso paulatino por el cual el
ser humano va perdiendo sensibilidad a
ciertas cosas y empezamos a aceptar lo
inaceptable vamos en detrimento de
nuestra dignidad personal
aceptando cosas que tendrían que ser
inaceptables
traigo a cuento este concepto de la
banalidad del mal porque es una
enfermedad silenciosa una enfermedad
silenciosa cuyos primeros síntomas
emergen cada día a cada rato en nuestra
realidad hoy aquí y ahora sí en este
méxico del siglo 21 estamos teniendo
expresiones de la banalidad del mal y el
primer problema y la primera el primer
síntoma de que las células del que la
enfermedad está presente es que no nos
damos cuenta de ello que crece
silenciosamente
sabían ustedes que en los últimos siete
meses nuestro país ha vivido el proceso
más la etapa más violenta de la historia
contemporánea
hoy están muriendo 93 personas al día
esta es una cifra oficial 93 personas
están muriendo diariamente en mexico ojo
como resultado de actos criminales
violentos
[Música]
son cifras similares a países en guerra
en siria mueren 120 personas y es un
país pequeño invadido y en guerra desde
hace casi una década y mueren 120
personas al día
no es para regocijarse en méjico de si
decía yo muere 93 pero nunca sabemos
cuántas nos vamos a encontrar en una
fosa común más adelante es decir 93
tenemos contabilizadas y tenemos
conciencia y registro de que está
ocurriendo es la banalidad del mal si no
lo preguntaran ahora si estamos viendo
en un país violento quizá diríamos que
no que méxico es un país en paz es la
banalidad del mal ya que tener mucho
cuidado
en siria por ejemplo de esas 120
personas que están muriendo 5 son niños
perdón 2 son niños en méxico de las 93
personas que están muriendo cada día 5
son niños
eso tiene que ser inaceptable
este es un llamado también para nosotros
para la comunidad universitaria para la
ciencia para la reflexión y es un
desafío que tenemos que superar y lo
tenemos que hacer juntos hoy les quiero
hablar de eso también les quiero dejar
un mensaje esperanzador porque estoy
convencido de que podemos resolverlo y
lo que les quiero platicar hoy es un
método de trabajo para resolverlo este
método se llama el método la de la
seguridad total el método de la
seguridad total total porque nos incluye
a todos total porque es el único y es
determinante y es indispensable que lo
implementamos ya
déjenme comentarles yo veo gobiernos que
van y vienen y casi siempre veo
gobiernos nuevos avanzando por caminos
viejos es decir todos hacen lo mismo
yo nací hace 50 años aquí en toluca
estudiante pekín propio diciendo no
crecí en ninguna parte mucho
pero a lo largo de todo este tiempo cada
seis años veo la misma escena el zócalo
la plaza de los mártires de toluca con
patrullas nuevas uniformes
resplandecientes policías armados
equipamientos chalecos antibalas todos
hacen lo mismo y todos nos han llevado
al fracaso en el modelo de la seguridad
y lo seguimos repitiendo evidentemente
si hacemos lo mismo como dice la muy
trillada frase vamos a encontrar los
mismos resultados es el momento de
cambiar y ese es el propósito del modelo
de seguridad total un primer problema
que tenemos en la seguridad es que ni
siquiera la medimos bien
hay montones de cifras pero ni siquiera
la medimos bien deben explicar las
autoridades reciben en las barandillas
de lo que se conoce como el ministerio
público en las procuradurías llamadas
antes y más recientemente bautizadas
como fiscalías reciben las denuncias
asumiendo que sí que las personas cuando
somos víctimas de un delito o cuando
somos testigos de un bell delito tenemos
la obligación de acudir a denunciar ese
delito
pero todos sabemos que ya perdimos la
confianza nadie va al ministerio público
incluso cuando es víctima de un delito a
menos que sea indispensable nadie asiste
a denunciar un delito porque nadie está
esperando justicia quien llegue a serlo
lo que existe es un trámite necesitas el
papel para hacer un trámite para cambiar
el seguro del auto para que te cambien
el teléfono que te robaron para
recuperar la computadora que estabas
pagando por un trámite no vamos por
justicia vamos por un papel por un
requisito
pero el gobierno se contenta con atender
esos delitos que son denunciados sabían
ustedes también cifras oficiales del
inegi de cada 100 delitos que se cometen
solo 4 se denuncian
solo 4 por eso cuando un gobernante un
presidente municipal un gobernador el
presidente de la república sea quien sea
dar resultados en su informe nos habla
de cifras fantásticas que no
corresponden a la realidad porque él
está concentrado en el 4% mientras que
nosotros como ciudadanos estamos viendo
el 100 por ciento de problemas que
padecemos en la comunidad entonces el
modelo de seguridad total el primer
planteamiento que hace miramos bien las
cosas y medir bien las cosas para eso
existe un método científico y medir bien
las cosas significa no esperar que la
gente a que la gente venga a la
barandilla ministerio público a
denunciar sino vayamos a donde está la
gente a todo el territorio municipal
estatal o nacional para preguntarle a la
gente qué es lo que está ocurriendo para
preguntarnos a nosotros y entre nosotros
si bien la universidad los académicos la
comunidad no puede y no debe sustituir a
la policía ciertamente puede y creo que
debe tomar la iniciativa para medir bien
este que este fenómeno que está
ocurriendo
el inegi les comento brevemente realiza
cada año una encuesta que se llama
encuesta nacional de victimización y la
levanta en todo el país es una encuesta
como lo dice su nombre nacional pero
tarda siete meses en levantar la
encuesta y cinco meses en procesar la
información porque es un esfuerzo muy
grande geográficamente de tal manera que
la que tenemos hoy por ejemplo con la
que los policías hoy están tomando
decisiones y los gobernantes están
implementando operativos supuestamente
de seguridad es una fotografía de la
criminalidad pero es una fotógrafo
fotografía tomada hace más de 12 meses
por supuesto que sirve para efectos de
análisis pero no es útil para efectos de
operación policiaca
entonces que se requiere el modelo de
seguridad total en ese primer punto lo
que plantea tenemos que hacer estudios
micro regionales estudios municipales de
victimización para que sepamos qué es lo
que está ocurriendo hoy en el municipio
respectivo para el caso por ejemplo sí
que sepamos qué está pasando hoy en
toluca pero en todo toluca en susan
urbana y en su zona rural en todos y
cada uno de esos pequeños espacios en
los que para efectos de seguridad se
divide el territorio municipal que le
llaman cuadrantes en todos los
cuadrantes no solo donde se denuncian y
mucho menos donde hay cámaras de
seguridad porque eso es sólo una
pequeñísima parte estamos atendiendo la
punta del iceberg y consecuentemente el
esfuerzo es inadecuado y es totalmente
ineficaz segundo problema que tenemos en
méxico y que el modelo de seguridad
pretende resolver en méjico quizás el
único país del mundo en la policía no
investiga
no investiga
por absurdo que parezca no investiga
porque además la ley le prohíbe
investigar hay dos artículos de la
constitución que absurdamente determinan
el artículo 21 constitucional y el 16
dicen que la investigación la debe
conducir el ministerio público
por eso hace un par de semanas que hubo
un asesinato de un chico secuestrado al
sur de la ciudad de mexico que
desafortunadamente quizá ustedes lo
recuerden
cuando supimos más información del caso
nos platicó su primo a través de los
medios que cuando él supo la noticia de
inmediato fue a la calle a buscar a su
primo y encontró el auto abandonado y
fue corriendo porque había una patrulla
cercana decirles y explicar lo que
estaba ocurriendo la respuesta de los
patrulleros fue de levantar tu acta al
ministerio público porque mientras no
puedo hacer nada
se perdieron minutos valiosísimos que
podrán haber arrojado pistas en el
transcurso de las siguientes de las
siguientes horas esa misma noche el
chico secuestrado fue desafortunadamente
asesinado
la acción de proximidad con prontitud y
con eficacia de la policía pudo haber
sido la diferencia no lo sabremos nunca
pero pudo haber sido la diferencia
cuál es el problema que siendo inhumana
y siendo poco solidaria la respuesta de
los policías que creen es legal
los policías respondieron lo que la ley
de les dice no puedes iniciar la
investigación si no te lo ordenó el
ministerio público ministerio pública
quiera buscar en una perdón por la
expresión pocilga en una oficina
desagradable antihigiénica a perder el
tiempo muchas veces para poder tener un
trámite eso es absurdo pero además no
pasa en ningún otro país del planeta más
que en mexico entonces segunda medida
del modelo de seguridad corrijamos esta
parte y si corregimos a esta parte lo
que vamos a hacer es que el ministerio
público ahora el fiscal como pasa en las
películas de otros países el fiscal no
se va a dedicar a investigar el fiscal
no investiga no pocos de ustedes han de
haber estudiado derecho y en la facultad
de derecho no nos enseñan investigar
crímenes no están hechos para eso
el fiscal tiene que ser un abogado que
lo que hace es armar jurídicamente el
caso el caso así como se escuchan las
películas cuando la investigación que
salas en la policía está bien armada
está articulada tiene fundamentos
sólidos y hay un argumento lógico que
explica la racionalidad la causa y
consecuencia del acto criminal
el abogado toma el caso y lo presenta
ante el juez porque el ministerio
público o fiscal tiene que ser el
defensor de la sociedad es decir señor
juez yo ministerio público vengo porque
es interés de la sociedad que esta
persona presunto culpable de tal o cual
delito recibe el castigo que merece
conforme a la ley es la función del
ministerio público no tiene que andar
recibiendo denuncias y mucho menos
investigando las es otra la tarea que
tienen que hacer con un agregado
recuerden el cambio de nombre de
procuraduría fiscalía no sólo fue un
cambio de nombre también fue un claudio
untado en un cambio orgánico es decir
hoy el fiscal general de la república
depende del presidente de la república y
el fiscal general de justicia del estado
de mexico su jefe no es el gobernador es
autónomo desde hace algunos años por eso
es absurdo que este personaje autónomo
mande sobre la policía que depende de
este otro personaje que es el gobernador
entonces tenemos una maraña y un
desorden que lo de menos sería que
estuviéramos mal organizados el problema
está que esa mala organización nos lleva
a una pésima operación de tal suerte que
el sistema está colapsado y por eso pasa
lo que todos nosotros y muchos de
nuestros amigos y conocidos hemos
padecido
como ven cuando uno dice hay que
resolver el problema de la seguridad en
méxico parece un monstruo de mil cabezas
y parece un fenómeno imposible de
abordar pero cuando como el método
científico lo sugiere analizamos el
asunto es decir lo separamos en sus
partes entendemos cómo funciona cada uno
de ellos podemos armar un nuevo modelo
que tenga una concatenación más lógica y
más eficaz de tal suerte que
sintetizando medimos mejor la
criminalidad
permitimos que la policía investigue
depuramos las tareas del ministerio
público esos 13 eslabones de la cadena
funcionando mejor como una cadena de
bicicleta van a permitir que el
siguiente eslabón que es el del juez
haga mejor su trabajo
y que los culpables no salgan libres
[Música]
y que el que la hace la paga si logramos
eso vamos a restablecer un sistema de
derecho en méxico y vamos a acabar con
la impunidad y vamos a recuperar la
confianza no sólo en los gobernantes
sino a la confianza entre nosotros y
vamos a facilitar los negocios y la vida
comunitaria la civilización pero lo más
importante porque yo veo ahora en la
sociedad mexicana que empieza a crecer
como si fuese un cáncer estas
expresiones de la banalidad del mal
banalidad del mal es cuando alguien nos
dice no se preocupen era un conflicto
entre bandas como si eso fuera normal
fueron disparos cruzados y la gente
andaba por ahí como si eso fuera normal
como si justificamos la violencia contra
una mujer y como se justificaron la
violencia contra un anciano eso no es
normal y que no nos lo nieguen y que no
nos digan que eso es normal y que
nosotros tengamos la capacidad de
resistirnos a ello porque no es normal
vivir así
el modelo pues de seguridad total tiene
esos cuatro componentes en los que
quisiera yo insistir midamos bien la
criminalidad y aquí la comunidad
universitaria está llamada a la acción
mejoremos organicemos bien a la policía
y permitamos la calle investigue y
realice investigaciones profesionales y
eso le corresponde centralmente al
gobierno empezando por esas reformas a
esos dos artículos que ya mencionaba yo
en tercer lugar depuremos las tareas del
ministerio público para que recupere su
vocación natural y que sea de veras un
defensor de la sociedad y no su
adversario
y con todo esto exijamos a los jueces
transparencia eficacia apego a la
legalidad de tal manera que podamos ir
pasando juntos de manera articulada de
eso que yo hoy veo con sentido de
urgencia la banalidad del mal a la
normalidad del bien que al final es lo
que necesitamos todos no solo porque lo
requerimos no solo porque es una
exigencia sino porque no los merecemos
merecemos vivir con seguridad trabajar
en armonía y gozar de la paz muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]